hello everybody how y'all doing whoo
super excited to be here whoo my name is
M are you see her they/them pronouns we
good we're getting better great good at
Microsoft but I'm also a game designer
and an installation artist I make
beliefs in art that you hear I'm going
to talk about the piece called
I built for great yep hello there we go
god I'm much better so so this is a
piece called computational inner that I
built for the come out and play Festival
in San Francisco it is a generative
site-specific poetry walk which means if
you go to Fort Mason in San Francisco
and download this free app on your
iPhone and put your headphones in as you
walk around a robot will make up and
read you poetry based on wherever you
walk through the park so if you walk by
the canons you'll hear sort of pseudo
nonsense poems about war if you walk by
the waterfront you'll your poems about
the sea that sort of thing so I'm really
excited to be here today to talk a bit
about this project and the process of
making it so there are a lot of
resources out there if you want to learn
how to generate poetry or generally do
cool things with precedes reality and
text but I think this project is unique
in a couple different ways that I
haven't heard a lot of people talk about
the first is its interactive in the
sense this is not a Twitter bot that is
spewing text out into the void for you
to consume this is giving stuff to you
and it is responding based on what
you're doing and working in dialogue
with you and but also that input that
it's getting back is not a mouse and
keyboard or touch input though our
controller it is all of these real world
data sensors things like GPS and
accelerometer and motion data
third-party online API is like weather
and so I haven't seen a lot of people
talk about well what does it mean to use
these sorts of real world tools and data
sensors as inputs and procedural
generation and things proxy and systems
whose output escape screens so I'm
generally going to be talking about what
was what was the process of thinking
through and conceptualizing and
designing this piece we're gonna start
by touching on
the history and tradition of immersive
theater and site-specific narrative art
installation the computational flair
plays into and look specifically at the
ways these arts of things create these
joyful emergent behaviors that actually
sort of mirror what we like and think is
interesting about procedural texture
narration and digital proc gen then I'm
going to talk a bit about the actual act
of generating the poetry and
specifically using neural networks and
then finally looking at well okay so we
have these pieces in place how do we
actually put them together the
prototyping and design process of
building this and some of the contect
achill tools and conceptual ideas so if
all goes according to plan besides
hearing about this lovely little weird
poetry art walk you can do you learned a
little bit about sort of how how the
immersive theater world works how you
can design proc gen tech systems and
what sort of tools you have and then
finally how you can put those together
with these sorts of specific real world
data situations and how to take all
these building blocks and holistically
put them towards you know designing art
this is there are technical topics here
but this is a talk about using artistic
tools to convey meaning not about
optimization so this is a theater piece
called sleep no more how many people in
here have heard of this or seen it or
have any idea awesome that is a larger
group than I thought fantastic I love
strange live this is a theour piece by a
British theater group called punch-drunk
it is running in New York and Shanghai
and it is run in Boston in the past it
is a sort of interpretive dance no word
retelling of Shakespeare's Macbeth and
Hitchcock's Rebecca but it is not a
piece of theater that you sit in a
theater and watch for two hours in front
of a proscenium the set as it were is a
six or seven story building that takes
up a full city block in Manhattan you
show up you put on one of those white
masks they tell you you can go wherever
you want but don't talk and don't take
the mask off and you have two or three
hours to wander through this space and
do whatever you want you can pick an
actor and follow them all night you can
hang out in a room and watch people come
in and out you can go to the library and
read all the books or go to the candy
shop and eat the candies for two hours
and those are all equally valid ways to
experience Sleep No More but the real
magic to me isn't all of these weird
unique experiences you'll have although
those are great it is after the show and
you go to a coffee shop or a bar with
your friends and
debrief and talk through what are the
things that I saw are the things that
you saw and what are the unique moments
you have because each of you will have
had unique and different moments and not
just I saw this thing where as you
didn't or I saw it in a slightly
different order than you but you will
inevitably have like a sequence of
events that feels so perfectly connected
to each other that it had to have been
intentional and yet no one else in your
group experienced anything like that and
it wasn't explicitly designed by an
author it just happened as a result of
the systems in place and the systems in
place are interesting because it is not
like this is not particularly complex it
is Sleep No More as a very rigidly
plotted piece of theater where every
actor knows exactly where they are at
any given moment in time so the fact
that these sort of interesting things
can emerge out of that is fascinating to
me and the word emerge there is very
intentional your many of you are likely
familiar with the concept of emergence
and emergent behavior was the thing the
game designers talk a lot about and a
lot of other sort of more scientific
fields but if you're not familiar in
very broad strokes you may be familiar
with Connolly's game of life which is a
simple set of cellular automata rules
that establish how should these cells
act but it turns out when you when you
sort of let this thing play out you get
these higher-level emergent behaviors
arise that wouldn't otherwise be
predicted by the rules like this is a
glider it's a shape that sort of very
naturally forms and then itself
replicates across the 2d grid nothing in
the Conway's Game of Life rules suggests
that will happen but it naturally
emerges as a result of the simpler level
rules that exist and so this is
something that we game designers talk
about a lot we usually think about it in
terms of if you are trying to create
certain types of games that are very
complex and have these rich dynamic
interactions and complex choices we
talked about emergence a lot as a design
tool that lets you design very very
simple gameplay systems and let
interesting things come out of it like
this is a game called spelunky they're
sort of very famous for the sort of
thing and it has lots of very low-level
game mechanics like if you kill a
skeleton it leaves its skull behind
that's an object you can pick up and
carry around there are arrow traps that
shoot at the first thing that falls by
them you can kill a skeleton take its
head and drop it down a pit and let the
arrow trap hit that instead of hitting
you so very very simple gameplay
mechanic roles that emerge to create
something more complex and interesting
but we tend to think about these sort of
low-level things as algorithms whether
it is cellular automata rules that may
or may not be acted out by a computer or
things like in video games like spelunky
where these are algorithms that code is
executing what's interesting to me is
that is essentially what is happening
with sleep no more there is emergent
storytelling happening but instead of
this unexpected and interesting behavior
emerging out of the intersection of
digital algorithms it is coming from the
intersection of this very complex but
static system of the actors moving
around a space and you as a human having
the freedom to wander through and go
wherever you want bounded only by your
ability to physically move through this
space without annoying the cast enough
for them to kick you out and it's worth
bookmarking here that not only not only
is this happening is sort of interesting
unexpected things are emerging at the
intersection of these but also because
it is happening to you physically in a
physical space that active embodiment
really matters and this this is true for
anything like this
they're like watching playing a game of
spelunky and feeling like something
unique is happening to you it feels
special purely because it is happening
to you watching someone else do the same
thing doesn't have that same importance
so this is another piece that probably
fewer of you are familiar with this is a
so Janet Cardiff is this amazing sound
artist who makes these audio walks and
so this one was a piece she did in New
York in 2004-2005 for the public art
fund culture long black hair that is a
30-minute audio walk through Central
Park so you would rent a discman from
her a tape recorder and she sort of
walks you through the park and there's a
framing narrative of why you're going to
different places but that's really not
as important as the binaural audio
soundscape she's created so she uses
positional audio to create this
alternate reality lay it on top of the
real world not IR with 3d goggles just
through sounds but there is magic sense
of as you walk around you will hear
police sirens on 59th Street or a couple
arguing behind you and you're not sure
is this actually happening in real life
or is this part of the fiction and to be
clear this is a static recorded piece of
audio the 3d positional audio that makes
it sound like someone is behind you is
baked in so if you turn your head they
will move with you and completely break
the Allu
Janak Cardiff manages to get you to not
turn your head through incredible
psychological design that I could give a
whole other talk about but but what's
last thing about the piece isn't just
those specifics but the overall effects
that it shapes your relationship with
the space after having done her long
black hair
I feel differently about that corner of
Central Park than any other space in
Central Park in a way that is really
different from just doing an audio walk
there or taking a walk through the park
she somehow weaves this magic where she
takes whether you want to talk about
like in games we talk about the magic
circle of a game or if you want to talk
about suspension of disbelief and
theater or whatever terminology you want
to use there's a sense of like the hyper
reality of engaging in sort of a capital
a art piece that she manages to extend
that circle to all of the things that
just happen to you as a result of
walking through the park so every
interaction you have with a stranger
every little bird you see feels like
part of this meaningful and magical
experience and this is all very
intentionally done and very carefully
done the way her piece intersects with
the real world is very subtle and very
clever whether it is hearing sirens on
59th Street which work because there
will always be sirens on 59th Street as
long as there are cars in Manhattan - at
one point she walks you through the zoo
and she has you look at some animals
that are right there and they're great
and then she has you look at a polar
bear exhibit I it is very clear now
going to Central Park that those polar
bears have been dead for at least a
decade and I don't know if they were
there when the piece was written or not
but it doesn't matter because the way
that ephemerality ties into the piece
makes that feel incredibly meaningful
and then throughout the rest of the
piece she has you interact with
strangers and do things to make a fool
of yourself and she's taking this
confident leap of faith where she knows
that the spontaneity and randomness of
the real world is going to provide
something interesting which to me this
is very similar to sleep no more it like
besides literally being this embodied
art piece the same way that Sleep No
More creates interesting emergent
situations by letting you roam free in
this very rigidly plotted out space this
creates emergence at the intersection of
the static 25-minute piece of recorded
with the real world and everything that
will happen when you're in a public
space as long as you are psychologically
Prime's to pay attention to things and
it works really really well this is not
the point of this talk but if you're
ever in New York you should absolutely
do this you can download it as a podcast
there was a link earlier the slides will
be up it is one of my favorite pieces of
art so to bring our focus back so a
couple years ago I was doing research at
the MIT Media Lab all about real world
storytelling and how we can use fiction
to connect people to public spaces and
very much the same way as Janet Cardiff
I was looking at here's this amazing
audio walk Janet Cardiff has done some
other audio walks nothing else I have
ever seen even comes close to this there
are people who have done similar walks
that don't quite capture her magic
partly because this is clearly a very
very hard design problem and you need
both a lot of audio production skills
and a lot of experience making this sort
of thing so my hypothesis was we can get
more things like this to exist in the
world if we lower the barrier entry for
creating them maybe one way to do that
is to bring in smartphone technology and
the giant bundle of data sensors you
have in your pocket to give creators
more tools that make the creation of
things like this simpler and so
originally I was working on more
narrative pieces bringing in
inspirations for things like chooser and
adventures and the Renaissance and
indeed narrative games but I quickly
shrunk the focus back down to something
non narrative to work on like what are
the lower level building blocks of
making things like this hence the come
out and play Festival in San Francisco
being in Fort Mason which is a lovely
Park that I feel like none of my friends
had ever seen there is a there is a fort
area that is pretty popular there's a
farmers market there are a bunch of
great restaurants and event space
there's a grassy area that is a pretty
popular park spot but the park has all
of these other weird nooks and crannies
and little hidden paths covered in
flowers and cannons and a chapel and a
community garden and all of these
beautiful spaces and so part of my goal
is thinking given that we have access to
the space that is in the middle of San
Francisco what can we do to get people
appreciate the space and know that it
exists it's like drew inspiration from
two very disparate things the first were
Twitter BOTS and I have a pet theory
about Twitter bots which is that they
are really really good Skinner boxes but
each each time a a bot tweets like this
one on the left two headlines it grabs
two different headlines from Google News
grabs the subjects from Google News and
swaps them by various Kazemi every time
that tweets it is like pulling a
slot-machine lever or a pigeon pushing a
button to get a tweet a treat nice and
intentional pun every time like every
time that that bought tweets it is not
necessarily funny it is often not funny
which in a sense makes it more
interesting than something that gave you
a treat or a funny joke every time it is
this it is this generator where most
times this might be relatively
uninteresting garbage but that means
that both maybe this time it'll be
surprising and interesting and funny but
also then those times that it is it
makes them feel that much more
meaningful and on the complete opposite
end of the information economy and
attention economy spectrum we have
meditation chimes and so I apologize I
am not particularly experienced in this
field so please correct me if I am wrong
but my understanding is there are there
are certain forms of meditation where
you find value and having these chimes
whereas it was sort of naturally with
meditation you want to be focused on the
presence and on nothing but because we
are human and fallible our attention is
going to drift and so a technique that I
have personally found useful is having
these chimes but every so often a ring
to help snap your attention back sort of
counter intuitively having this
distraction from the outside world
serves to remind you what you're
supposed to be doing and lets you get
outside of your own brain and so if
what's beautiful about Janet's cardiff
piece are the moments where the outside
world serendipitously intersects with
this pre-recorded audio and like there's
a sense with which that piece sort of
functions like this Twitter bot Skinner
box where Cardiff is leaving these hooks
out knowing that some of them but not
all of them are going to lead to moments
of serendipity with the real world
and to me that could also acts like
meditation chimes but if you're
trying to appreciate this walk through
the park and your attention is going to
be wandering because you have a lot
going on and you're won and you need
time to think having these moments of
serendipity could just serve to sort of
jolt you and nudge you back to realizing
oh right I'm in this beautiful space I
should appreciate it and be more aware
and more present and I think that I
really like about this idea is so I'm
here at Strange Loop I'm clearly a
person who thinks about technology and
loves dealing with technology but this
is a concept that comes at it from the
concept first and the technology second
you can imagine a version of this that
is just like Cardiff's walks as a static
piece of recorded audio but we have this
clear metric where at least the
hypothesis is that if the goal is to
give you these moments of serendipity to
draw you back into your walk in reality
in the present the more moments of these
that exists the more effective this will
be at that so this isn't really a
quantifiable metrics probably have sort
of a qualitative metric where if there
are ways that technology can increase
the number of times that we have those
moments it is likely this piece will be
more effective at its artistic goal this
was a very weird way to approach an art
piece but I think it worked for me so
the final piece of the puzzle was the
poetry a couple years ago deep learning
started started to go through the
Renaissance that it's currently
undergoing a very very popular piece
that came out about that time is Andre
Carpathia's article about the
unreasonable effectiveness of her
current neural networks I don't have
time to dive all the way into how
recurrent neural networks work or
specifically a tool that he talks about
called char RNN which is a
character-based recurrent neural network
which is a technique for generating text
I think it's probably for the sake of
time we're gonna talk a bit about you
can think of char rnns as sort of
souped-up markov chains and we'll talk a
little bit about Markov chains in case
you don't know what those are
so how many of you are familiar with
Markov chains who have done anything
with them okay great about half of you
maybe a little more so it's a pretty
relatively straightforward method of
basically using statistics for
generating texts if you have ever seen
any sort of like course ebook style
Twitter bot that asks you like you can
generate tweets that look like your own
tweets
that's probably using a Markov chain
this year is King James programming
which is trained on a combination of the
King James Bible and yes ours texts
so when broad strokes with a Markov
chain if you took every piece of text
that Shakespeare ever wrote you would
basically sort out what is the
probability that a given word would come
given previous words so if you're
looking at the previous three words if
you if you see the phrase Romeo my Romeo
statistically speaking wherefore is
probably coming next and you can
generate a chain of these where then you
would look at my Romeo wherefore and
grab the next word sample that ad
nauseam until you have some text that is
statistically like but aesthetically
only sort of like Shakespeare but Markov
chains aren't great a particular thing
they are bad at is context and
remembering long term history because if
you're only looking at the last couple
of words it's really tricky to get that
like one specific problem they're bad at
is things like if you open up a
parenthesis you're probably not gonna
get a matching closing parenthesis
because it will have forgotten that it
existed by the time it would get there
so and the one variable you really have
control over is if you're looking at the
previous n words you can jack up or down
that end but if you put a turn it up too
high things are gonna get really
predictable if you're looking at the
previous ten words of a sentence it's
pretty statistically likely you know
what the next word is and there's no
wiggle room to play with that whereas if
you drive it all the way down it's gonna
have too little context and you can very
easily get into loops like where were
you're cycling through something and
something and something and something
and not getting anywhere which is really
sort of again ignoring the technical
differences from an artistic standpoint
charr RNN basically solves that problem
that through through having through
being sort of a neural network with many
many layers it has a much higher
contextual awareness of what is the long
term history and can sort of do a lot of
subtle subtle negotiating of how much
should I be waiting
the most recent text versus remembering
the long term context at least to the
extent that it makes sense to be
attributing intentionality to these
things like specifically for this
matching parentheses problem this is in
Carpathia's article he has a bunch of
char are many examples trained on the
Linux source code and so this this
specific example doesn't literally
compile but you could imagine it
compiling and of course it is it's and
like of course it is complete nonsense
but at least you can see it's gets
things like the higher-level structure
of what does a c function look like it's
also worth noting this example shows how
good it is at catching explicit
structure and lexical structure and
things about how how you actually
position characters after each other
part of where char RNN gets really
interesting with prose is it doesn't
just capture the explicit structure it
is also very good at intuiting implicit
structure which is also a problem
because then it is going to blindly
reproduce a lot of our own racist and
sexist and other problematic things that
we don't really notice so when you look
at a lot of char r and n text like it
looks really interesting because it's
noticing patterns that you didn't even
consciously notice in your own work but
it also leads to a lot of things or if
you don't know what you're doing as a
creator you're gonna lead to some pretty
vitriolic things also as an aside
everything i'm talking about here this
is these are very powerful methods for
generating texts in general if you are
actually generating texts to use in a
project you probably don't actually want
to use markov chains or neural networks
the thing about these sorts of
techniques that generate their own
structure rather than having structure
imposed on them by you the author is
they're pretty difficult to integrate
into any other sort of work I should
have put a link there's a woman named
Kate Compton who has an amazing article
called I think like so you want to build
a generator that is all about creating
different sorts of techniques for
generating different sorts of things she
also created a wonderful tool called
tracery shown here as a tracery desktop
app that i maintained is also a chief
Botts dun quik is a tool for making
twitter about using tracery it's sort of
a mad lib style grammar approach that in
practice like if your goal here is you
want to know how you can make something
funny on the internet that uses
generated text that's probably actually
what you want
I also forgot to include a link but if
you are if you are interested in the
sort of neural network style approach
the tool that I would use today that
wasn't available a couple years ago is
this thing called GPT to which open a I
took char are n n these exact techniques
and trains trained it on a couple
gigabytes of links that they source from
reddit their insight was we can use
reddit not as a source of text but as a
source of quality indicators for what
other sites we should be looking at and
they have released a couple different
models that you can use to generate text
and specifically you can sub train it so
instead of taking a whole bunch of 20th
century poetry like for this project and
training an aryl network you can sub
train GPT too and because it has this
context of terabytes and terabytes and
terabytes of existing human English text
you can get results that feel much more
naturalistic and surprising but so that
brings us all the way back to this beast
which I'm going to sort of hand over my
actual generation process I ended up not
training my own neural network because I
was lazy and didn't want to gather lots
and lots of poetry I found there is a an
artist named Ross Goodwin who did some
phenomenal work at ITP around generative
poetry he made this beautiful camera
that you take a picture of something and
it gives you a poem about it so once I
had that the question was well how do I
actually integrate this with the
physical space so I'm going to talk
about a couple different issues I ran
into in different ways that I told them
so my initial hypothesis sort of laid
out earlier was more sensors is better
the this piece will be better the more
that people feel like it is connecting
to them and speaking directly to their
experience and they have more of these
moments of synchrony where the poetry
somehow relates to the real world
therefore the more sensors the better
we're gonna use GPS so we know where the
player is we're gonna use motion sensors
so we know how quickly they're moving
we're gonna use weather data so we can
give them special experiences if it's
raining or something like that we can
detect you know are they there in the
morning versus the evening weekday
versus weekend fall versus summer is it
their first time or 20th time are there
other people doing this experience in
the park we can't ride and dodge them
towards each other and I ran into a very
very common problem in any sort of
procedural generation which is an
algorithm that isn't legible
might as well be a random number
generator it turns out this sort of
thing is pretty new even even me doing
it myself as the person who programmed
it a thing
there is no mental model for I'm
listening to a podcast that is different
if it's raining or I'm listening to
Spotify and the faster I run the music
changes so this felt like nonsense and
noise and not particularly helpful so a
big part of this project and what
actually testing it in person drove out
was shrinking everything down to be as
simple as possible so the end result
ended up using just GPS and location
data so if you take your poetry charr
RNN it has three inputs basically you
decide how much text do you want which I
found just based on the network that I
had sampling it there is like a certain
length of about 50 characters
consistently produced the most reliable
output you have the temperature which is
roughly akin to a Markov chain like
choosing the end like a lower
temperature is more conservative and
give it given a probability space of
what what characters can I pick it is
going to choose ones that are
statistically more likely to appear so
you're going to get text that is more
likely to be coherent but also less
interesting and maybe a little more
repetitive a higher temperature is going
to be more volatile more likely to be
incoherent but potentially more
interesting and then you also have the
seed text so if you're starting by
saying here's some text with
statistically likely to come next you
need a piece of sample text to kick
things off so I ended up using the your
movement speed as as an input to the
temperature under the assumption that if
you are moving very quickly you are
probably doing this because you are
interested in sort of seeing what it is
and when I get some funny content and
then leave so giving you a higher
temperature is going to give you that
whereas if you are moving more slowly
you are probably more deeply engaged
with it
I can I can tone it down a bit and make
things a little safer for the extent of
giving you a potentially better
experience and then for a location I
ended up creating all of these different
regions with them within the park you
can sort of see up there where each of
these manually had 20 or 30 different
seed texts
so anytime we need to generate you
another two lines of poetry we look at
where you are we grab a seed text from
that we grab a temperature based of how
quickly you're moving and generate you
some poetry and so this is where testing
in person was absolutely essential this
this tool here is the thing that I built
myself but basically let me walk around
the space in person and say this is what
I want the regions to be physically say
this space that I'm standing right now
is going to be one corner of this region
which as an aside I am very very
fortunate if any of you have dealt with
GPS on smartphones before you know that
it can be very very inaccurate
especially when you are in large cities
like San Francisco I don't have time in
this talk I have given talks about this
and how GPS works under the hood so this
was in San Francisco which being in a
big city means that there are a lot of
tips and tricks to improve location
services but it is also not near any
buildings not near any Hills and right
on the waterfront which meant in
practice I was getting five meters or
less of GPS accuracy which is completely
unheard of but it's also magical because
it meant I could stay in artists brain
and work on thinking about location as
just this is the Platonic ideal of where
the player is rather than having to
[ __ ] around with data being imperfect
and having to design around that so the
other the other thing that this drove
out was I knew early on that I cared a
lot about the transitions between spaces
and for a lot of the different reasons I
ended up just smoothly fading between
the two for any given line of poetry if
you're at an overlap I will generate you
one or the other but I knew that even
though it was important to the piece
that you can do this you can start
anywhere you can go anywhere you can do
it for five minutes or five hours a lot
of people were going to start by the
fort because that's where a lot of the
parking is and in the fort the first
place they are probably going to go that
is a meaningful shift like there are a
couple different reasons in the fort but
broadly speaking there's a set of stairs
that lead up to the park and this was
going to be a lot of people's first
experience with huh is this piece
actually going to respond to me what
does it feel like for this to be
generative
so this space felt really important to
sort out how did this actually change
and so I started out using the iPhones
altimeter if you have a newer ish iPhone
it has a very very precise sensor that
can tell you exactly how high above sea
level you are to the level that on these
stairs I could know exactly which step
you were on but that turned out again to
be completely illegible especially when
the granularity of the rest of the piece
is like oh yeah you're sort of in a
grassy area or you're sort of by the
cannons saying you're on the bottom
third of the step versus the middle
third did not make any sense it didn't
even seem legible to separate it out
based on are you coming down the stairs
or are you going up the stairs so the
end result I don't know which of these
buttons is a laser pointer well yeah you
can sort of see there is a dedicated
region that is just the stairs so while
you are walking on the stairs you hear
poetry that vaguely references sort of
elevating yourself but that's about it
and all of this was only possible
because I was able to do all of this on
site in the physical space which is
really difficult given that I don't live
in San Francisco so I assume most of the
people in this room are software people
of some flavor and we are used to the
idea that we have very very tight
feedback loops and there are there like
gradations in there like writing an
executing unit test is generally faster
than higher-level automation tests is
faster than manual QA is faster than
deploying something to end-users and
waiting for data to flow in but that is
also still a relatively bounded time
space as opposed to hardware or real
world stuff is really really hard
especially when in my case where that
might mean all right I'm gonna be in San
Francisco in two weeks and I might have
a day or two what can I get done so I
needed to be able to really optimize
that time in the physical space which
meant being able to do everything that
didn't need being in the physical space
and do that anywhere so I partition this
out into a couple different groups of
things where they I think this
of high-level tactical thing here is it
is worth taking time to design your
design process so yeah I had three
different bundles of work the first was
I had this poetry generator it needs to
be able to spit out poetry I need to
figure out what are the range of
temperatures that are valid I need to
test given some hypotheses about here's
some seed text that will generate poetry
that is both interesting and relevant to
the broad sort of space I can do that on
my computer without anything else once I
had that here hearing like reading
poetry in my computer or having a
text-to-speech BOTS read poetry back at
me still doesn't give me the aesthetic
experience of walking through a physical
space which I can still capture without
having to be at the specific Park so I
had a special build of the app that
wasn't region-locked to Fort Mason I
could just open the app anywhere and it
would read out poetry and I could press
a button to change regions so I could
still get a sense for here's what this
type of poetry feels like as I am
walking through the physical world as
I'm walking to like a different space
wherever I'm walking I can press a
button and simulate shifting regions in
the app and get an aesthetics feel for
how does this work at a high level in
the real world and then having all of
that taken care of
that and making sure that things were
such that I could always have my latest
code running on device that meant that
when I'm on site I could focus that on
on-site things
it's as I explained earlier that meant
high level conceptual questions like
what how should this work what does it
feel like to be doing this at all and
then later on this was essential for
tuning out fine-tune details like
sorting out have exactly those
transitions between spaces other than
the stairs worked and how to best
implement the subtle background audio so
I had these janet cardiff style
background sound scapes so while you're
in the community garden you hear birds
chirping when you're in the grassy park
area you hear kids playing when you're
by the chapel there are bells off in the
distance and my first attempts at those
were incredibly hand fisted and without
being able to sit there in the park and
try something out and then go and sit
down and at the Edit table and tweak
some variables and try it again
it it would have felt incredibly
overwrought and would have detracted
from the
rather than adding to it so I guess I'm
a high-level question though why bother
with any of this this is a lot of work
compared to just making an audio walk or
making a Twitter bot into a thing that I
care a lot about as an artist and I feel
like I talked about this way too much is
that the way you interact with any sort
of digital system meaningfully affects
your relationship to it even even
separate from arts like you feel
meaningfully different about an app you
use on your phone versus using the exact
same service as a web app on your
desktop like it is a different emotional
connection and even if you're using
using it on your computer with a MacBook
Pro flutterfly keyboard versus like a
juicy clack e mechanical keyboard and so
as an artists who is interested in
making things that connect people to
each other and other systems of the
world and get them excited about the
world why would you not play with that
artistic palette and use all of these
tools at your disposal so I think making
things like this and putting in this
effort is really important and hopefully
you do too but if not that's also okay
hopefully you have so glean something
useful out of this whether it is
thinking about emergence in immersive
theater or procedural text generation
with the neural networks or other
methods or thinking about designing
process to test integrations with
real-world data but above all hopefully
this is some sort of inspiration you
should go out and make some more weird
things in the world Thanks
[Applause]